boulangerie viennoiserie et pâtisseries
Philippe laroudée ancien finaliste de
l'émission la meilleure boulangerie de
France et grand gagnant du concours
régional du pain bio vient d'ouvrir sa
propre enseigne à Maisons-Laffitte
Crin-Blanc à Crin Blanc va retrouver une
pâtisserie on va dire traditionnelle
déjà avec certaines comment dire
revisite on dit aujourd'hui sur la
pâtisserie mais surtout des produits
aussi un peu oubliés quoi et beaucoup
beaucoup de pain bio biologique de
farine biologique voilà et de blé
anciens aussi on va remettre au goût du
jour
en l'honneur de l'historique équestre de
la ville mais aussi parce que Philippe
laroudé et passionné par les chevaux et
pour lancer cette nouvelle boulangerie
il a décidé de collaborer avec Alicia
ancienne candidate du meilleur pâtissier
2022 j'ai accepté du coup cette belle et
jolie collaboration à craint blanc bah
déjà à Maison-Laffitte c'est magnifique
c'est un super beau à l'endroit c'est un
vrai honneur et j'en suis vraiment très
fier
timide un peu mais je suis trop contente
alors Alicia je l'ai découvert sur la
meilleure pâtisserie et j'ai trouvé ses
créations bah super sympa innovante et
voilà et c'est un talent amateur qui m'a
vraiment bluffé quoi et vous pourrez
retrouver les créations de la jeune
strase bourgeoise au sein de la
boulangerie notamment sa rose pour
l'instant tout ce mois de novembre vous
allez pouvoir découvrir ma rose que j'ai
pu faire et élaborer dans le meilleur
pâtissier sous l'attente du meilleur
pâtissier donc j'en suis très très fière
parce que du coup ça vient de ma tête et
vous allez pouvoir la retrouver en
vitrine chez Crin Blanc Norbert Tarayre
animateur de la meilleure boulangerie de
France était également présent
ça fait maintenant 5 ans que je connais
Philippe puisqu'il a il est passé dans
l'émission de la mer boulangerie de
France il était à Sartrouville et il a
ouvert plusieurs boulangeries donc un
blanc aujourd'hui et donc je vais
suggéré ça serait quand même génial de
pouvoir donner la chance à une un
candidat qui est amateur dans une
émission du meilleur pâtissier de
pouvoir y installer dans sa boutique des
pâtisseries revue est corrigé bien sûr
avec son appui et son œil professionnel
et donner la chance et l'opportunité à
une amatrice de pouvoir devenir
professionnel
et en décembre vous pourrez retrouver la
bûche de Noël made in Crin Blanc ainsi
que d'autres petites surprises